[Musique]
michel y est retourné ses bouteilles de
vin dans cette est ça qu pas parce que
son vin et puschnik
technologie mais plutôt pour aller
consigner ces contenants
dans le cadre de la modernisation de la
loi sur la consigne sept projets pilotes
sont en place dans six villes du québec
jusqu'au 31 janvier 2022
ici michel pu rapporter des contenants
de boissons en plastique en verre ou en
métal grâce à une blogueuse automatisé
et projets pilotes
proposent différentes de récupération de
contenants de manière à pouvoir évaluer
quelles sont les meilleures manières en
fonction des régions qui sont visés la
nouvelle loi prévoit que les entreprises
qui mettent en marche et les contenants
sont responsables de la gestion des
matières résiduelles
à elle seule la saq met en marché plus
de 200 millions de bouteilles de verre
par annick la société d'état qui a
longtemps misé sur la collecte sélective
se dit prête pour le grand virage ça
fait plus de trente ans contre 1 action
là dessus qu'on investit dans la
collecte sélective dans la valorisation
du verre mais à un moment donné il a
fallu se rendre compte que malgré des
taux de récupération très élevé plus de
90% il ya seulement environ 30% du verre
qui était réellement recyclées à la
feuille la nouvelle consigne permettra
de produire un verre beaucoup plus pur
que celui retrouvé pêle mêle dans le bac
de recyclage une pureté nécessaire pour
le recyclage du verre au bon sens robert
julien de chez 2ème ressources un
conditionneur de verre attendait ce
moment avant c'était une économie
linéaire donc post consommation s'était
directement l'enfouissement tous ces
emballages aujourd'hui c'est qu'on veut
en faire vraiment donner son sang sur
circulaire et la beauté de la chose du
verre c'est que un couple est
conditionnée refaire en bouteille il se
le fait à l'infini c'est donc un
changement majeur pour l'environnement
selon karel ménard et oui c'est une
révolution parce que c'est bien beau
récupérer des dizaines des centaines de
millions de bouteilles mais il faut
avoir un système de collecte efficace
pour avoir un système de conditionnement
peut pas dire seulement envoyé une
bouteille comme ça chez un recycleur
faut la préparer la conditionner et il
faut avoir les giesler et il ne marchait
pas et le marché est prêt quand robert
juillet le jugement la nouvelle conseil
au québec pour faire en sorte que l'on
va de karak fournir de répondre à une
demande parce que vraiment en ce moment
ne répond pas à la demande les citoyens
devront développer de nouvelles
habitudes et se déplacer recyc québec
croit qu'il faut simplement usé de
stratégie lé projet pilote vise
justement à tester le
geste citoyen par rapport à son à sa
routine quotidienne
donc les points de dépôt sont placés de
telle façon qu'ils sont entre plusieurs
commerces par exemple
michel lui n'y voit aucun problème une
année dessus du consommateur c'est sûr
un peu comme un compost la conseil
élargi devrait officiellement être mise
en place dès décembre 2022 les montants
de consignes seront établis à 25 scène
pour les bouteilles de vins et
spiritueux
edison pour tous les autres contenants
ici et les insérer radio canada montréal